testing testing ah yes the mixer does
need to be on very very good okay a lot
to discuss glad that you are with me
today not even sure where to start
honestly we have incredible video of
William Barr completely you know how
sometimes you hear about explosive
testimony this was implosive testimony
William Barr just completely breaking
down and actually causing numerous new
problems that now the Trump
administration is going to have to
contend with I'm going to show you
momentarily some important moments from
the testimony it's stunning we also now
have the full text of the letter written
by Robert Muller
to William Barr Donald Trump's
propaganda Attorney General it doesn't
it's like not even the right way to
modify a person can't be a propaganda
Attorney General but that's what William
bar is and that's what I'm calling him
we have the full text of this letter
that I spoke about on the program
earlier today where Robert Mulder wrote
to Barre and said you know what you're
saying is causing a problem and for
someone as measured and controlled as
Robert Moeller this is what you would
call a scathing letter letter right this
is like for someone who doesn't a moat
in any way smirking is the equivalent of
uncontrolled laughter for Robert Muller
who is controlled quiet barely said
anything even through spokespeople
throughout this investigative process it
is the equivalent of a scathing letter
letter by robert muller and before i get
to the video of Camilla Harris
Kamala Kamala Harris
taking apart william bar and getting him
to expose horrible horrible things you
know part of what is I think enjoyable
about the video that I'm about to play
for you is that William bar embodies the
smugness that we have come to know and
be disgusted by of Donald Trump and
everybody around him and he starts to
look visibly visibly perplexed and
confused and maybe even realizing that
he's going in a direction that is
extraordinarily extraordinarily damaging
and you'll see why when I get to this
video and then we'll do let me ask this
for people that are in the chat and I
know people are just coming in
do you want me to look at the testimony
video first or do you want me to look at
the bar letter the Moller letter to bar
first I'm willing to start with with
either depending on what people want so
I'll take a look at what's in the what's
in the chat in terms of what people want
and I'll go so testimony what else are
people saying video testimony letter
testimony video letter letter letter
testimony letter testimony letter letter
letter testimony
it seems pretty 50/50 so what I'll do is
I'll just like toss this pen and if it
points more towards me I'll do testimony
first otherwise I'll do the bar letter
and it is pointing to me so we will
start with the testimonial okay so
before I get into the video welcome to
the live stream if this is your first
this is different then the clips we
upload because it's live unless you're
watching a replay which means you can
participate the best way to participate
is using the super chat function
yesterday during my livestream with
Stephen destiny bunnell the second we
took a few super chats but I will I will
get to all Super chats today and I see
that a couple have already started to
come in that's the dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window if you want to
call in and I see people already saying
they want to call in at six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty sign
up for a membership ok this program is
mostly funded by memberships
at david pakman.com slash membership if
we get ten of them i will open up the
phone lines when we're done looking at
the video and the bar letter and it'll
be a great time I actually see there's a
super chat here from Joseph din Z's
who's already saying open up the phones
mark wants to prove you wrong I don't
know who mark is but I will gladly open
the phone lines during the livestream if
and when we get 10 new members at david
pakman.com slash membership you can save
off of the normal prices with the coupon
code this is 20/20 the normal prices are
pretty damn reasonable I'm not going to
lie but you can take the discount or not
and if we get 10 new members we will
open up the phone lines don't troll the
live chat that
are a number of moderators they have
been deputized to mute people as
necessary and also to ban or block
people as necessary don't troll the live
chat you can also hit the join button
down below and that will make you a
YouTube channel member which is a whole
other way to support the show so let's
get into this I I could have picked a
whole bunch of different parts of this
testimony to sort of show you the extent
to which William bar is not a law
enforcement official in anything other
than name other than title I guess I
would say he's a propagandist partisan
actor meant to get Donald Trump out of
trouble he's an expert in covering up
presidential wrongdoing and the most
glaring expose of that where his
smugness actually was interrupted by
visible concern and having to ask people
behind him and look around and ask for
questions to be repeated was when Kamala
Harris interrogated him quite frankly
cross-examined him I'm not saying I
support Kamala Harris for president this
is not a prop up comel a thing so please
if you're gonna start posting that stuff
it that that's that's not what this is
she destroyed William Barr let's start
getting into it and from the very first
question it already was very bad for
William Barr take a look has the
President or anyone at the White House
ever asked or suggested that you open an
investigation of anyone that question it
was you you did anyone ask me to open an
investigation well what was that
question again and it goes downhill or
anyone at the White House ever asked or
suggested that you open by the way this
look on Cory Booker's face he in the
first twenty two seconds of this
exchange realizes he has a front row
seat to something that's gonna get
pretty good an investigation of anyone
yes or no please sir the President or
anybody else seems you would remember
something like that and be able to tell
us yeah but I'm trying to grab
the word suggests I mean grapple there
have been discussions of matters out
there that they have not asked me to
open a investigation but perhaps they've
suggested I don't know I wouldn't say
suggest inferred so this is everything
but a know so far the question is have
has Donald Trump or someone in his
administration encouraged suggested
invited said that they want an
investigation into particular
individuals and anything short of know
is a real problem now there are question
as to why Kamala Harris moves on here
and I I get why you'll see why in a
second but this is this is a very
disturbing answer from William bar
because as you know there is a movement
now to now that Trump has been cleared
of everything which of course is
[ __ ] investigate Hillary investigate
the investigators investigate you know
Christopher Steele whatever and so this
is a really important question here and
Kamala Harris moves on a very disturbing
answers from from William Bar in your
March 24th summary you wrote that quote
after reviewing the special counsels
final report will show that no I'm
asking a question in your March 24th
summary you wrote that quote after
reviewing the special counsels final
report deputy attorney general
Rosenstein and I have concluded that the
evidence is not sufficient to establish
that the president committed an
obstruction of justice offense look at
Booker now the special counsels
investigation produced a great deal of
evidence I've led to believe it included
witnesses notes and emails witnesses
congressional testimony witnesses
interviews which were summarized in the
FBI 302 forms former FBI director
Comey's memos and the president's public
statements my question this is key is in
reaching your conclusion did you
personally review all of the underlying
evidence so understand she's saying you
told us that based on the evidence you
weren't going to indict Trump
secure transfer obstruction did you look
at the evidence that you claimed was the
basis for that decision no we took no we
accepted the statements in the report as
the factual record we did not go
underneath it to see whether or not they
were accurately accepted it is accurate
and made our say you are accepted the
report as the evidence yes you did not
question or look at the underlying
evidence that supports the conclusions
in the report no hmm
did mr. Rosenstein review the evidence
this will come back to haunt him and
supports the conclusions and the report
to your knowledge not to my knowledge we
accepted the statements and the report
it anywhere accumulation of the evidence
is true did anyone in your executive
office review the evidence supporting
the report no yet you represented to the
American public that the evidence was
not quote sufficient to support an
obstruction of justice how could you
know what the evidence did or didn't
support if you didn't look at the
evidence the evidence presented in the
report this is not over this is not an
Asterius process in the department of
justice we have Prospero's and
declination memos every day coming up
and we don't go and look at the
underlying evidence we serve would you
support the characterization of the
evidence as true as the Attorney General
of the United States
you run the United States Department of
Justice if in any US Attorney's Office
around the country the head of that
office when being asked to make a
critical decision about in this case the
person who holds the highest office in
the land right and whether or not that
person committed a crime would you
accept them recommending a charging
decision to you if they'd had not
reviewed the evidence well that's a
question for Bob Muller he's the US
attorney he's the one who presents the
report so this is a key mistake that
William bar makes he's saying don't ask
me about this ask Robert Mulder because
he's the prosecutor and this allows
Kamala
to get directly into well who exactly
did make this decision and Cory Booker
is thinking who had gone right but he
was the Democrat who went before her
damn she's doing way better at this than
I did but it was you who made the
charging decision sir you made the
decision
key moment okay the two seconds of
stunned silence right there are the
realisation by William Barr that this is
not going in a good direction for him
parts the president in the Prospero and
in the declination memo you said it was
your baby what did you mean by that it
was my baby to look to let to decide
whether or not to disclose it to the
public and whose decision was it who had
the power to make the decision about
whether or not the evidence was
sufficient yeah probably make a
determination of whether there had been
an obstruction of justice
prosecution memos go up to the
supervisor in this case it was the you
know the Attorney General and the Deputy
Attorney General who decide on the final
decision and that is based on the memo
as presented by the US Attorney's Office
and we can move on will you agree to
consult career DOJ ethics officials
about whether your refusal from the 14
investigation said okay let me skip
ahead a little to get back to the party
discussion I'm not your that he would be
responsible for supervising the Russian
investing I'm sorry now I went too far
let me go back this is the roses you
have consulted with them about the 14
other investigations that about the
Muller case have you consulted with the
career DOJ ethics officials about the
appropriateness of you being involved or
recusing yourself one of the 14 other
investigations that have conflict of
interest clear confidence what's my
conflict event I think the American
public has seen quite well that you are
biased in a situation and you've not
been objective and that would arguably
be the conflict oh you know I haven't
been the only decision-maker here we go
it's take the Deputy Attorney General on
Eisenstein who was approved by this
Senate 94 to 6 with specific discussion
on the floor that he would be
responsible for supervising the Russian
I'm glad you brought up that so this is
now the broaching of a completely new
issue which is wait wait a second did
you make these decisions about
indictments and prosecutions or did rod
Rosen Stein make them because rod Rosen
Stein was a witness in that
investigation and and if you're telling
us William Bar that someone who was a
witness in the investigation is making
prosecution decisions about that same
investigation we now have we now have a
real problem on our hands and Komal
Harris is all over and we had a number
of senior prosecutors in the department
involved in this process both career and
non-career yes I have another question
and I'm glad you brought that subject up
because I have a question about that
earlier today in response to Senator
Graham you said quote that you consulted
with Rosen Stein constantly unquote with
respect to the special counsels
investigation or import but Deputy
Attorney General Rosenstein is also a
key witness in the firing of FBI
director Comey did you consult with D
I'm not finished did you consult with
DOJ ethics officials before you enlisted
rod Rosenstein to participate in a
charging decision for an investigation
the subject of which he is also a
witness pretzel time my understanding
was that he had been cleared already to
participate in it but so you had
consulted with them and they cleared it
well not exactly no I think they cleared
it when he's when he took over the
investigation you don't know whether
he's been cleared of a conflict of
interest he would be participating if
there was a conflict of interest so
you're saying that it did not need to be
reviewed by the career ethics officials
in your office I believe it I believe it
was well I believe it was reviewed and I
and what we also point out this seems to
be a bit of a flip-flop oh boy the
president's observers were checking that
you're not answering the question
directly did the ethics officials in
your office in the Department of Justice
review the appropriateness of rod
Rosenstein being a part of making a
charging decision on an investigation
which he
also a witness in yeah Mike so as I said
my understanding was he had been cleared
in his right everything's fine he says
so what what beardless Steve Bannon as I
like to refer to William Bar is telling
us here is that it's not really clear
how he determined that it's okay for
Rosenstein to be making prosecutorial
decisions it's not really clear who even
made the decision but it's definitely
clear that whoever made the decision
didn't look at any of the actual
underlying evidence and instead you used
a political interpretation of the Moller
report as they decided to understand it
to say within 48 hours of getting the
Moller report ya know Trump's good
Trump's good on obstruction we don't we
don't need to worry about that this
this man needs to be removed okay this
is a man who needs to be impeached
period in William bar it is completely
unacceptable
it is a comical subjugation of the
process of justice checks and balances
the way these things are supposed to
work and congratulations to Kamala
Harris here for exposing him and again
that one of the funniest parts of this
entire thing is cory booker sitting
there after sort of like getting in one
or two reasonable questions but not
really doing a great job of exposing
william bar sitting there with a smirk
that is both interested in what Kamala
Harris is doing but also recognizing
that she is just way way better at this
than he is an extraordinarily good job
and by tomorrow's program we're gonna
continue talking about this testimony we
will probably have significantly more
sort of detail about the full scope of
the trouble that this guy got himself
into okay I'm gonna get to the Moller
letter to Barr in a second but let me do
let me do a couple things number one a
lot of people want the phone lines
opened I'm willing to do that if we get
10 new members on our website we have
one so far and that's Philip Weinberg ok
Philips signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership Philip used the coupon
code which gives them a discount that
coupon code is this is 20 20 that saves
you 40% and we are at 1 out of 10 tens
not a lot okay there's 2,500 people
watching right now if only 1/3 of 1% of
you get a member
ship at david pakman.com slash
membership these phone lines will be
open before you know it and I guess
there's people who want to call me out
call in and call me out on all sorts of
different things and I welcome that
that's not something that I'm scared of
and I look forward to hearing from you
if you want like this isn't what we
would call an unpublished discount if
you use the coupon code save 35 on the
$60 a year membership it'll drop it to
25 bucks that's not a coupon code that
is being mentioned anywhere other than
this stream you'll get a membership for
just 25 bucks and that's a fantastic
deal and it'll get the phone lines
opened and by the way phone line
priority can be had if you sign up and
include your area code in either the
first or last name field when you become
a member I will make a note of your area
code and what if and when the phone
lines get opened you will get to get on
the phone with me first so that is
that's happening and I think that that's
a very exciting thing okay
let's get to some super chats because
there are a whole bunch that are going
in coming in I already talked about
Joseph din Z's once the phone's open so
mark can prove me wrong we'll see if
that happens
Nabil Kaveri says David you rock bro
thanks for going live my pleasure
Cathy Farrar is a new member on YouTube
we'll count those although we only keep
70% of YouTube memberships we keep like
98% of website memberships but will
still count Cathy she is number two of
the evening
new maid you mosa says take my money
David ten British pounds I appreciate it
real life Joe Lee is a new member that's
new member number three appreciate the
You Tube memberships remember we keep
almost all the money when you sign up on
our website we only keep 70 percent when
you sign up on YouTube Sam Dean from
Australia says g'day the Australian
election is May 18th since T rump is
probably mentally deficient
what stands would you like our party
leaders to take on political relations
with America now and into the future
cautious reservation is what I would
advise around Donald Trump unfortunately
when he tells you something you can't
really believe that he's going to stick
to it as we've seen with the Iran deal
and
so many other things so I would advise
extreme caution for Australian elected
officials
Peter qu Rainey with a $9 99 cent super
chat Thank You G says DP DP DP DP DP
thank you very much Andrew Bette kee
with an eighth New Zealand dollar super
chat why of recent congressional
testimony has just been grilling from
our Senators and Representatives and not
enough substantive questioning well
listen what is substantive depends on
what you think is important right I mean
at this point in time with William Barr
we have a blatant a extreme propagandist
who is playing the role of a law
enforcement official that needs to be
exposed and thus I think the grillings
make a lot of sense the progressive
voice wants to know my thoughts on face
sitting no thoughts their thoughts on
Boston versus Milwaukee I'm a Celtics
guy yeah what else can I say
Celtics Celtics all the way Terry James
with a $5 super chat can a politician
shift public opinion on an unpopular
position or should they follow the
public well Kent you're saying ken day
and then later you're saying should they
I think both politicians can influence
public opinions but they can also they
also should be representing their
constituents and one of the primary
problems we have with our current system
of government is that we see elected
officials that are mostly doing the
political will of corporations rich
people and other people who are already
elected officials rather than their
constituents and it's a sort of
fundamental problem with representative
democracy
Anthony Watson with a dollar ninety-nine
super chat says nice work
hugo mick chunky oh i grew up with a guy
named of chunky hugo McConkey is a new
member that is let me throw a hold on
that's one I've lost track one two three
four and the burger Terminator is new
member number five of the evening we're
targeting ten and I'll open up the phone
lines at six one seven eight three zero
4750 real-life Joe Lee
he says hey David what about my
membership I don't know what you mean i
I don't know what membership you're
referring to but if you have one I very
much appreciate it enter name says why
is Mark dice obsessed with you I don't
know that he is I mean there was the
thing with mark conspiracy theorist mark
dice a few months ago where we had like
a really weird private exchange on
Twitter we went private on Twitter and
he told me some really really strange
things and I went public about what
those were and it was kind of a one
one-off incident I don't I don't know
about him being obsessed with me beyond
that answer name says thoughts on Kyle
kolinsky saying you are a centrist had
no idea that he said that I was texting
with him yesterday I mean I don't think
that that's accurate
I just did my political compass test and
I also did some others that people had
me do there's one called like eight
values or eight eight something I forget
what it is I did every political test
people threw at me and I came out very
very left on on all of them so I think
it is a if Kyle said that I want him to
defend it with facts because a facts
don't care about feelings or something
like that I once heard Tate Tyrell Oh
says possible strategy for Bernie to
pass up Biden I don't even know what
that means for Bernie to pass up Biden
do you mean to pass him in the polls I
mean the only strategy I recommend
politicians take is tell us honestly
what your political positions are and if
they make sense and appeal to people
people will vote for you kind of naive
and simplistic but that's the way that
it should work
amazing shooter says David will you ever
interview Bernie any time he wants I'm
ready just say the word enter name says
Kyle called you a centrist to Nikko
house I have no idea what that is or
what that means but as I said I just had
my my work up I had the equivalent of a
political blood test done and it came
out very left very left and I'm willing
to take any political test to prove my
credentials
Keith sends a $2 super chat
be gang samurai zombie gangs test
samurai I don't know what that is says
David you and destiny are like the ken
and Ryu of the left now ken and Ryu I
remember there's what was that video
game I used to play growing up it's
either final fight or Streets of Rage I
think it is where you would pick Ken
roux or it wasn't like Hegar or
something like that the third character
you could play us Lee Leone Jones lion
Jones says do you think bar will turn up
to the house tomorrow don't know if he
does I'll be watching and Austin Clarke
sends a one dollar super chat okay do do
people want me to take phone calls at 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 if so we are looking for
10 new members at david pakman.com slash
membership you might wonder how on earth
does this program exists what is it that
is going on that allows this program to
exist either because you like it and you
want it to continue or just you don't
understand how something so horrifying
to you can exist and the answer is not
George Soros not the Koch brothers not
YouTube ad revenue which is very
irregular but its memberships it's just
people who say hey David I kind of like
what you do and I'm gonna support it on
your website and there are 2 coupon
codes currently available which will
give you the Members Only bonus show the
commercial free audio and video streams
all of that stuff at a huge deep
discount who doesn't like discounts if
you use the coupon code this is 20 20 on
any membership you'll save 40% okay that
means a six dollar membership is just
three dollars and 60 cents a month that
means a 60 dollar a year membership is
only 36 bucks etc etc subtracting 40%
from things however there is like an
extra special coupon code available
which is not being promoted anywhere
other than right here and that coupon
code is save 35 nospace all lowercase
save 35 the coupon code save 35 only
works on a 60 dollar a year membership
I see people typing in the chat I'm
getting invalid coupon code it only
works on the $60 membership and it'll
drop the price from $60 to just $25 let
me thank a whole bunch of awesome new
people actually let me I'll do that I'll
do that in a bit let me do the let me do
the bar
Moeller letter first just because we do
now have it and I want to talk about it
okay we now have the letter that Robert
Moeller sent to William bar let's take a
look at it dear attorney-general bar I
previously sent you a letter dated March
25 that enclosed the introduction and
executive summary for each volume of my
report marked with redactions to remove
information which could be protected so
on and so forth
accordingly the enclosed documents are
in a form that can be released to the
public
consistent with legal requirements and
department policies I am requesting that
you provide these materials to Congress
etc as we stated in our meeting on March
5th and reiterated to the department the
introductions and executive summaries
are accurately summarized this offices
work and conclusions
the summary letter the department sent
to Congress and released to the public
late in the afternoon on the on March
24th did not fully capture the context
nature and substance of this offices
work in conclusions if you understand
legalese and you understand restraint
and you understand Robert Moeller this
is scathing okay he is saying that even
though as he says multiple times he sent
a whole bunch of stuff that fully
explains the investigations results to
the Justice Department that what was put
out by William bar does not capture the
context of what was said by robert
muller it doesn't capture the nature of
what was said and it doesn't capture the
substance of the work and the
conclusions in other words it's
inaccurate it's a mischaracterization
bar Moeller rather goes on to say we
communicated that concern to the
department on the morning of March 25th
this is sort of like
her my previous email right there is now
public confusion about critical aspects
of the results of our investigation this
threatens to undermine a central purpose
for which the department appointed the
special counsel to assure full public
confidence in the outcome of the
investigations
this is Moeller saying you're not
telling the truth about what we said and
this defeats the purpose of doing an
investigation what's the point of doing
it if you're just going to
mischaracterize characterize what it is
that we did while we understand that the
department is reviewing the full report
to determine what is appropriate for
public release this was before the
release of the report a process that our
office is working with you to complete
that process need not delay release of
the enclosed materials
this is Moeller saying release what I'm
sending you ASAP because it's that
important
release at this time would alleviate the
misunderstandings that have arisen and
would answer congressional and public
questions about the nature and outcome
of our investigation
it would also accord with the standard
for public release of notifications to
Congress cited in your letter listen I
mean if you if you're of the mindset
that there's nothing to see here
then I'm not gonna convince you
otherwise right but if you understand
legalese and you understand the way that
Robert Muller has comported himself
throughout this probe this is robert
muller saying what you're doing is
horrible effectively i don't know how to
summarize it any further okay let me say
thank you to some new members that have
signed up a bunch of people have signed
up and i want to thank them because it's
so important Brian gamma or gamma or
gamma has signed up on our website
Tim Morse is a new member thank you Tim
I really appreciate it
Steven Crowley has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership Luke Bryan
is a new member at david pakman.com
slash membership rufus Cardwell is a new
member
at david pakman.com slash membership
paying full price mind you appreciate
that gabriel Caston BAM you know that is
so funny I have a story about that last
name Caston bellman my family has a
really good friend from
Argentine friend of the family in fact
his adds a long story but doesn't matter
and he once told me that as a goof when
he would go places and order food and
they would say in the US which is a
common he would visit the u.s. from
Argentina and you know some places you
go and you put your name in and then
they call out your name and he just
thought it was really funny to give the
name Diego Castille boom and so for a
while I just found that really funny
when I was like 17 or 18 and I would do
the same thing and seeing Gabriel cast
and Bom sign up just brings back
memories from my youth I appreciate that
jury James is a new member on our
website Sean Murphy has signed up jury
and Sean thank you I really appreciate
your support
Matthew Haller is a new member on our
website Kurt Kellner has signed up and I
really do appreciate that
Dallas Spivey has signed up and has also
included their area code so if and when
we open up the phone lines which we're
going to because we have so many people
signing up Dallas is going to get wonder
if Dallas is the name or saying like I'm
doubt I'm from Dallas I don't know that
will be the our first caller when we
open up the phone lines
berdal Nielsen has signed up taking
advantage of the save 35 massive massive
discount code and then Drake gent Jensen
has also signed up on our website so
that is more than enough new members to
justify opening up the phone line so I'm
gonna get the phone lines opened at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 once again the number 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 maybe a couple of people
can type it into the chat so that I
don't have to keep repeating it so if
people want to start calling in we can
get set up for that and I will take
phone calls momentarily in the meantime
a few other super chats I want to
address a herd of space duck says quack
thank you for extra information every
day my pleasure
slash says what are your thoughts dem
changing position towards Israel and
what are your suggestions to change that
greetings from Germany I don't
understand
epidemic which Democrats change their
position and in what way I apologize I
don't I don't fully understand the
question
real-life Jolie says sorry David I
actually sent that right after you said
that there was just one member that was
not me really when I did just add a
youtube membership to my site one to
make you say my name again okay I'm not
sure if that's some kind of like
voice-to-text thing
Joseph Dizzy's mark dice is in your chat
showing us your fake news it's time to
meet your maker mark Dice is watching my
stream that's interesting maybe he'll
call in I don't know do you think
teacher wages issue should be raised yes
teachers are underpaid in just about
every state I saw an interesting study
or graphic yesterday saying that
teachers are underpaid in every state
they are the least underpaid in Rhode
Island and in mostly red states they are
extraordinarily underpaid Bobby beans do
you have honest optimism for democracy
with the increasing spread of
misinformation and lack of critical
thinking no I have cautious optimism
I have tentative optimism that something
will improve but I can't say that I have
honest and full optimism economist akin
itis a co notice says when will you take
the bread pill reading Kropotkin uh yeah
I'm not sure about that rufus cod well
with the 2499 super chat thank you so
much amazing shooter says destiny and
Pakman 1v1 soon in basketball who will
win I don't know
so destiny and I are both 5/8 and he
said he doesn't really play basketball
and I used to but haven't for a while so
I don't know who would take that but if
I go to LA or he comes to Boston we'll
do it a horror fan for life says sent
you a super chat yesterday no answer I
apologize for that we didn't get to
every super chat yesterday but I wish
you had just included what the question
was here because then I would be able to
just address it right away
okay let me get to the phone lines the
phone lines are open at 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 let me first look
that new member who wants to get on from
area code nine one two who is not here
okay so 9 1 2 if you want to get on I'm
standing by for your call let's start
with the caller from the 972 area code
who's calling today from 9 7 2 yeah this
is Alex Watkins hey Alex what's going on
hi let me start by saying I'm a big fan
I didn't think I was going to get
selected I watch you all the time
thank you I hate that I have to do this
but there is both it appears that
there's something on in the background
and your connections going in you out
can we solve either or both of those
issues I yes I hope I just I turned off
whatever's in the background and I will
walk over to the corner of the room
hopefully get better connection very
good people call from the corner of the
room yes it is the optimal place and I
know I can't believe I'm speaking to you
this is crazy
well what's going on what's up uh I was
you know you know who the progressive
voices I'm sure and I'm sort of a fan of
him I guess you could say and I was
watching a video of his the other day
and he was basically implying you were a
fan of Joe Biden by the video you put
out where you said that you know you you
you you thought he could debate well
against Trump and that's basically the
only context that I thought she meant
right you know you thought he could beat
Trump he was a good debater and that was
it can you clarify for us if you feel
that you support Biden in any other way
no you've said it I mean I do think that
Joe Biden historically has been a really
good debater he embarrassed Paul Ryan he
I think he's a good debater and based
only on like I've reported polling
polling says Biden could beat Trump but
Biden's not one of the people that that
I am sort of favoring if he's the
nominee I'll vote for the guy of course
but yeah that's us you've clarified my
position perfectly as if it needed
clarification I didn't think it did you
know I just thought what am I gonna ask
him I guess I welcome about this right
but thank you so much for taking my call
David my pleasure for watching future
thank you
much very very good to hear from you
okay let me say a couple other
thank-yous because memberships are just
exploding I mean it is an explosive
situation on our website let a couple of
these richard martinez is a new member
thank you so much and Brooke Babcock is
a new member which I really appreciate
and there was another area code
membership which I think I might have
missed here hold on nine one two we
mentioned break these things are just
flowing oh I see Oh Keith Clem
Keith Clem Oh potentially a
Massachusetts caller from the 508 okay
Keith thank you I see your membership
and if you call in we are looking for
who gets priority right now nine one two
and five oh eight which is funny because
if you're not one of those people and
you call in from those area codes you're
probably gonna get on pretty quickly
okay let's go next to our caller from
the nine to five area code who's calling
today from nine to five
actually that might be me on Robert
corner B I live in North East Bay east
of San Francisco and are in California
that is indeed you Robert great to hear
from you hi how you doing good so I just
wanted to ask I mean do you think that
Joe Biden actually has legs to to beat
Trump in the next election or or not
listen what do I know I mean I thought
Trump was gonna lose to Hillary so I'm
clueless right but but my assessment
right here is well yeah I mean the day
before the election I thought Hillary
was going to win and I was wrong so I
don't know I mean I'm not much of a
particular I didn't think much of it
until that tape about grabbing them by
the you know what came out and destroyed
the other guy and rolled right off a
Trump like it was nothing
yeah they say I mean what can I tell you
today what I can tell you today is in
general I don't think the best strategy
for Democrats is to run towards the
middle I think it's to run to the left
which is where the country is
increasingly moving Joe Biden represents
running towards the middle so that's
like a point against him
in hypothetical polling matchups Joe
Biden does well so that suggests maybe
he can beat Trump but what the hell do I
know you know yeah no I hear ya I just I
don't know with the Mueller report that
came out and everything I just I got
that same feeling when that came out
yeah I'm sure there's some damning stuff
in there but it's not gonna get out in
time before Tory before the 2020
election I don't think yeah I mean I
don't I just don't know but I mean I
think listen ultimately this is gonna be
turnout I actually think that the
particulars of the quote electability of
the candidates are less of a factor than
do we have a full and fair election and
what's the turnout like yeah that's true
I mean I didn't vote in the last
election because I didn't want to vote
for Hillary and damn sure didn't want to
vote for Trump what state you saw were
you voting in California then yeah yeah
well I voted first time I could vote was
Obama's first term I voted and yeah
turns out change is a very ambiguous
word you can change things either way
you want yeah
I voted for him again for a second term
you know the kid lists the drones of
that kind of turn we asked and I just
could not bring myself to vote for
Hillary or true right well listen I
would encourage you not to stay home
again and I get that in California it
didn't make a difference but just
participate okay yeah yeah what was
California 51 representatives I don't
remember off on the electoral I want to
say it's like 51 or 54 yes I can't
remember I've heard a heard Oprah thrown
around a few times and with the state of
things the way they are I don't know I
think she might have liked the Shubert
decide to run as the Democratic
candidate let's hope she doesn't Robert
I got a bunch of people holding so I'm
gonna let you go really appreciate the
call from the Bay Area let me deal with
a couple of Super chats here
Arai Suslov says red gels very
suspicious oh yeah I added a little bit
of orange to the hold on a little bit of
orange to the set just to test it out
see if people like it
bet it bet it all 33 if people aren't
obligated to answer questions as in
recent congressional hearings what can
be done or hearings futile that's not a
new question unfortunately that's that's
been an issue I don't know what can be
done and it's it is easy not to answer
questions
Keith sends a $2.00 super chat and Hugo
McConkey says hey David became a member
my area code is 774 okay I'm gonna go to
uni to you next I see you holding but
before I do that welcome to mark
Woodruff James forced Deanna Figgins and
Brodie Andrew Mulligan who is back on
the membership train very very exciting
okay let me pick up now on 774 is this
Hugo oh yeah oh good is this Hugo
McConkey okay what's going on what are
you calling from Massachusetts yeah
alright where are you in like Oxbridge
for example and go to be actually sorry
what what town okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah not the most exciting
part of the state I will admit but very
scenic it it's very depressing yeah I
didn't want to say it but you did yeah
yeah no I just wanted to start off by
saying you know I discovered your
channel a few weeks ago and as far as
you know unbiased keeping things
rational I haven't seen anybody take on
politics like you have and thank you it
appreciate it but um for a bigger
question I mean where do you see a
looking forward into the future where do
you see this country going in the next
you know 10 years or so I've been
struggling with that a lot Lee at least
the point where I'm considering just
jumping ship and going to Germany really
oh so how do you have some way to
legally legally move to Germany well I'm
a dual citizen of Portugal so it's like
I have that going for me so I can just
you know go to the EU but can't do my
thing right yeah I've been working on my
better citizenship and it's very
difficult because for the same reason as
you actually just to have more options I
mean it's
I can go back to Argentina anytime I
want and just get my passport updated
since I was born there but the economy
there is a train wreck I can go ahead
little Israel and go through the process
you know of what's called making Aliyah
but that's not super interesting to me
at this point in time so it seems the EU
is is an interesting possibility but
there's like crazy paperwork issues that
I'm having and anyway it's fascinating
that you're able to do that so the next
ten years it's there there's a couple
ways that it could go one do we start
taking seriously that over the last 10
20 30 40 years the economy has become
untenable unequal in a way that is
extraordinarily damaging to the sort of
fabric of the country as it it arguably
should be functioning or is it more of
the same more inequality more sort of
vulture capitalism and and everything
else we've been talking about that's one
question that will make a big difference
over the next 10 years number two do we
but not just we in the United States and
really the entire world say that there's
the crisis of climate change and we
can't sort of like pussyfoot around
mealy-mouthed pay lip service to doing
something and not really do it I mean
those those are the at the top level two
of the most important issues that will
dictate what it's like to live in the
United States in ten years and I have no
clue but what direction it's gonna go a
lot of it has to do with who we vote for
in 2020 and 2024 absolutely absolutely I
mean do you see kind of the problems
with you know the separation between the
high high class and the the poor you see
that kind of influencing like our cult
look our culture and how much becomes so
this toxic of course of course I mean
you have that that combined with social
media and the constant sort of looking
glass at celebrities and wealthy people
and materialism which all along I mean
poor and lower middle class and middle
class people knew that there were people
living that way like we everybody knew
it you know it's not like it was a
secret that was
hidden front from us that that that
exists but now that it is so front and
center in people's lives every single
day it's extraordinarily exacerbating
the issues you're talking about yeah I
could talk about that for hours yeah
well I'm gonna have a conversation in
two weeks I'm interviewing Cal Newport
and this is like one of his big issues
and I'll be I'll be talking to him about
it right now if he looks forward looking
forward to seeing that but hey I'm
actually gonna be in Northampton over
the weekend you want to grab beer oh I
live in Boston actually I didn't pop
okay okay Northampton yeah exactly but
here's my recommendation go to a great
place in Northampton for beer is the
dirty truth right downtown great beer
selection dirty truth I've been there
alright I encourage you to do it okay
thanks for the call appreciate it
take care okay a couple other super
chats and then I'll get back to the
phones horror fan for life says question
being a Howard Stern fan would you
include Jesse Lee Peterson as a whack
Packer seems to fit with some of the
best what are your thoughts
PS Trump obstructed wack Packers on the
Howard Stern Show I mean they frequently
have strange speech patterns and Jesse
Lee Peterson definitely has one so yeah
I mean I think I think there's something
there the sandbox bandit says with a
$2.00 super chat here you go David by
Pat something nice Sean Johnson says
what would it take to get Moeller in
front of Congress and would it help his
case against Trump bar I read one
article today that says that Moeller is
going to testify before Congress
although I don't it was a Democrat who
said he believes Moeller will I don't
know if that's the case Keith says I
liked all the blue and white for the
backdrop very tranquil let's take a poll
yeah I could go either way on the orange
I mean I'm just I'm just trying things
out but we'll see what kind of a
decision we ultimately make King Potato
Head says 9 1/2 at work didn't think
we'd get to 10 that fast oh okay
let me see if 9 1 2 is holding now I
guess you're saying you can't call in
because you're at work ok Phillip Young
says I like Pat and Pat likes me secrets
out folks
ok Phillip well thank you
appreciate that let me see if I have
anybody else holding from our priority
list then Denise McGee signed up and I'm
not seeing any other phone numbers that
match up so let me go next - oh man
there are some there are three callers
holding right now none or Jimmy from
Philly by the way but who have been
flagged as more unusual types of callers
and I don't know if people are
interested in me doing that you can tell
me in the chat but in the meantime I'll
go over to 909 I believe 909 is someone
who is not called in before who's there
hello this is Daniel hey Dan yeah
hi I'm kind of a new fan and I really
enjoy the content and - a lot of you
know political topics that you've been
talking about thank you I just wanted to
do that and I just wanted to call in and
talk about a new gang CBI's criticism
that I've been hearing from a lot of
progressive commentators such as
yourself at the humanist report yeah
so for context um you know many
progressives have seem to support you bi
in general but they believe and you know
correct me if I'm wrong but they believe
a shortcoming of Yang's plan is that it
doesn't help some of the people you know
currently on welfare programs and Social
Security I think that's fair right if
you're not releasing so I think the idea
is that if you if the if you if you bi
is opt in and it's replacing dollar for
dollar welfare benefits up to the first
thousand you're not really raising
people standard of living sure and um if
you gave me a chance I kind of want to
just present maybe an alternate of view
of that because I actually work in both
the tech industry that actually deals
with like financial services for these
people okay so um so on the offset I do
agree that it does not address a lot of
maybe someone's like the various the
very you know the very needy I think
that is a limitation to the plan however
it does also you know um you know I
think we can also still agree that it
does help the vast majority of working
Americans you know like just we know
like for example 4% are actually on
disability so the 95 percent that are
working that it would vastly benefit
from from a ubi correct so
this also helps people who are you know
working uncompensated work like
stay-at-home moms and dads so and also
it seems to you know it also seems today
would also empower those who are on
welfare but that technically do not need
to be right so you know people you mean
do not like what does that mean
technically don't need to be in the
sense that there are people for example
that would cook claim disabilities I
mean however small that segment could be
there are people who do claim disability
that could technically don't work in in
different capacities for house yeah the
free-rider problem is a problem with any
kind of an you know social insurance
thing butters I don't know that that
I've seen no evidence that that's a
significant enough group that I would be
heard of like making an argument about
policies on that basis sure I'm just
simply saying that is a segment that the
UVI could benefit them as well as they
wanted to you know transition from that
position right okay so on top of that so
there's also since I do work in like a
financial and tech sector like there are
people for example who trade in their
current benefits for cents on the
dollars you know you know people who
trade in food stamps you know for like
say 70 cents on the dollar so they're
actually seeing less than they're
actually receiving from the government
because they want the flexibility of
using that money to you know use it you
know in their actual needs I just I
totally understand what you're saying I
just think that you're you're kind of
like bundling a bunch of edge cases
together to defend the replacement of
welfare with ubi and I think that
however we evaluate the significance of
any of these edge cases I just think
that fundamentally this should not be a
dollar-for-dollar replacement for the
people on the lowest end of the income
spectrum because that is sort of like
self defeating it runs counter to why I
think we should have ubi mmm so I mean I
think you would you know like you were
saying before that you know as
capitalism you know grows and like I
guess a crony capitalist state which you
know income inequality is you know
running rampant that you know a UVI
would also still you know vastly improve
the lives of most working Americans not
even just the edge cases like I was
saying
the 95 percent or 90 percent that are
working below the medium you know median
income level right so like let me think
you're saying it would improve the lives
of the ninety percent of the bottom 50
percent is that what you're saying oh
yes certainly like for example most
people let's take the median incomes of
both the United States is $50,000 even
though you know vary state to state
obviously sure but an extra $12,000
vastly improves anyone from you know
working you know poverty level twelve
thousand and up which is the you know
vast amount of people right yes I agree
but it would improve it would improve
the lives even more of somebody who
earns a lot less than that and that's I
think the main argument for why we
shouldn't be just replacing welfare
benefits with it right so that's what I
was even including you know people who
are working gig contract especially yeah
thousand dollars in a poverty line now
that's why I guess I view you bi as a
superior policy over say a fifteen
dollar minimum wage just because there
are you know contract workers I mean the
gig contract work you know is increasing
you know as part of you know the
totality of our working force like it
seems like a fifteen dollar minimum wage
would make a lot more sense you know
twenty years ago as opposed to are
shifting economy now okay well now
getting into did the the these are
policies that a lot of times people talk
about them as either or but they
actually sort of address sure different
but yeah but overlapping issues but I
think that that basically for me making
sure that for the poorest people ubi
doesn't become a dollar-for-dollar
replacement that doesn't actually live
the standard of living other than in
these kind of marginal and and sort of
other ways that you're talking about is
a price it's more of a priority for me
than for you and it seems like we just
have a disagreement
oh yeah just one last point I guess my
main question is that while I you know I
I think we do see eye to eye and a lot
of these things and I do agree with you
I guess it just seems an interesting
standard to hold you bi as some sort of
cure-all or pen Asiya for all the social
ailment oh I don't think it is I mean I
hope you're not saying I hold it that
way I've actually all that it doesn't
address the fundamental
qualities and corporate control of our
economy no no certainly not
and III just I feel like it seems like
not at you specifically but I've seen
other progressive commentators you know
I guess it seems like they're holding it
to a standard worth they say about
though it doesn't solve these problems
at the edges but like most of say you
know Sanders is planned for you know
working America wouldn't address those
either it just seems like there's a
different standard of you know like okay
I don't support this therefore you know
yang you know yang you know platform is
not good for the country or you know $15
minimum wage and guarantee jobs is
better for most American I just you know
when I'm looking at an economic policy
for working America it just seems like
Sanders even you know I I do support
Sanders I really like him it just seems
like they don't we don't criticize his
plan saying oh it doesn't affect you
know people on Social Security does
affect people on disability
you know I think I think I got it okay I
appreciate the call Daniel I've got 20
people holding so I'm gonna let you go
but I think point made and I understand
what you're saying okay let's try
something a little different
let's go to Casey from the three six Oh
Casey three six Oh what's going on oh
hey man I'm just listening you can hang
up on me you but I don't even understand
what you're just listening what do you
mean
yeah I'm just listening on the program
for the phone buddy can the phone not
access to YouTube well I want to use
data you want to he's done but that's
okay with you do you understand yeah
okay so I guess you'll have to call back
in to listen right yeah okay all right
I'm gonna hang up on you now Casey thank
you okay let's see here Oh to it else we
got okay it's been it's been a while
I'll just go to Jimmy from Philly Jimmy
we it's been a while since we've heard
from you last few times I haven't gone
to you what's going on with you David
the last caller if this is indicative of
the people that listen to you I would
say well you're the most part you're
listening it's indicative of the people
why are we listen
came again that's why they listen no
they think you're telling the truth
David but I know different I am telling
the truth
y-yeah Candice Owens okay yeah and it's
funny servicing Bernie Sanders got
screwed in a rigged election and said
nothing the notion that he would stand
up for the United States when he did for
himself is laughable Jim why would you
find this exact thing already like last
time I picked up on you you called in
with this exact well no no no no no no I
called him left a voicemail I also
called in and said I would join if you
lifted the ban on me and you too Jimmy I
don't know what you're talking about is
your team and ketchup doing it what ban
are you talking about I'm banned on
YouTube okay I don't know anything about
it uh yeah you do because the moderator
is employed by you so you would know
employed people I'm here Jimmy okay whoa
whoa I've already made the statement
then I'm banned so you could lift the
ban David why'd you get bad I don't know
I'm going to said something bad were you
saying insulting things to other people
in the chat if they insulted me
absolutely I hit back right but then
they would have been banned first right
I don't know how it works with
progressives it's usually you know you
start something and then you ban the
person that fights back I just got a
message from our moderator that you're
not banned but you may not know how to
use a computer
no [ __ ] I don't use a computer I use
my phone I can't type in the live chat
no one answers me on YouTube anymore and
that means I'm shadowing it people might
just be ignoring you but I'm being told
you're not there no no no no when the
live chat I can't I'll tell you what
yeah
I'll tell you what tell me Jenni tell me
while we're on the phone when we're on
the phone I'm gonna see if I can type
when you're like chat all right let me
tell you right now what's that
let's take a look yeah give me a second
here reduce
wait a minute pack me
I'm waiting for it right now live all
right I'm gonna just type a few I took
KKK nope it's gonna come up I'm bad I'm
bad KKK may actually just beginning I
didn't write it favorite that was the
first letter I hit I'm just laughing 888
nope hey you know what you're right it's
not filling up so I don't know what that
means I'm being I'm shadow being David
that's what it means well listen I'm
sure you are invading me and I will join
under hatred you'll join under I give
you my word what does that even but that
well you have a coupon code for hatred
sorry yeah oh the coupon code okay yeah
yeah all right we'll have to get all
that - right all right Jimmy thank you
very much appreciate it appreciate here
okay let me see what else is going on
here let me do a couple super chats
because they are coming in a racist love
is asking if Ronald Reagan has seen the
new gels I don't know
Eduardo Castillo says David who will
take who will it take to hold Trump's
feet to the fire on policy media seem to
be going after Biden Budaj edge for
policy details yeah I mean well Trump
Trump doesn't know a lot of stuff about
any issue so that it's hard to hold him
to the his feet to the fire on policy
when he takes every side of policy
issues black flags are better says how
do I feel about ben shapiro excellent at
talking really really fast
comrade dao says do you think that
capitalism can be reformed i do the
nordic countries have done it
legislation is often written by the
capitalists who exploit the populace
crony capitalism is capitalism it is a
form of capitalism but i do believe that
the that capitalism can be reformed
yo soy baboso says who's a better
debater you or Kyle kolinsky I don't
really do debates so probably him I mean
I guess it depends on the context you
know when I get invited to debate an
issue I don't really know anything about
I just say I don't know enough about
that to debate so I don't know I guess
it depends on the issue and it also
depends on the other person right
because the format of the debate can
lend itself more to one approach versus
another pre-law says say goodbye Jimmy
dr. bad boy says I'll tell you what I'll
tell you what and Keith that says KKK
was posted by by picture my love okay
very good
I don't know what that means but it was
posted let's see let's go next to the
two one seven area code
who's calling from two one seven is that
Wisconsin I don't know why I think
Wisconsin's thank you yes I can hear you
who's this sorry could you repeat that
one time you know I do um I do think
that his policy is better suited for a
socially democratic country I do I think
you're spot on there okay cool thank you
thank you thank you thank you I wish I
just did what was good I mean I'm just
curious what can you tell me one more
time what your question is very very
unusual let me just take a
note about that so we can get that right
into the system okay I want to say
thanks to Michael Sedgwick what is
happening Michael Sedgwick is our newest
member this evening let's try the three
one three area code and see what kind of
what kind of results we get who's
calling today from three one three hey
do you mean hey that's you okay this is
Tony from Michigan hey Tom I have two
quick I have two questions for you yeah
if we have time sure
okay so my first question is I think I
remember a couple weeks ago I was
watching a live broadcast from you you
were saying something about a debate
with Candice Owens right I haven't
really been following much about that
but I just want to know what came what
came after that
absolutely nothing so really yeah that
so actually it's kind of a weird thing
oh man
so the people the third party that was
organizing it got in touch after that
segment and said hey you could have just
come to us and talk to us about it and I
said oh yeah no I mean I am talking to
you about it I'm also just talking about
it on the show
and then most recently they came back
and said Candice Owens is being
extraordinarily difficult so I might I
think it's dead in the water right now I
think she just doesn't want to do it man
that's what I was really looking forward
to something like that you and me both
you and me both um my second question is
a about Joe Biden and his polling data
and all that kind of stuff yeah um okay
so as far as I best of my knowledge
Biden like I don't think he's really
popular among any other groups that
Bernie is killing it in like young
people and I mean Bernie is polling more
or better in the black community yes so
the only sort of community that I'm
really thinking about in is killing it
it is older Democrats and I just like
there's so many more groups that bernie
is is mastering and abide it they
invited so I just want to know like what
your opinion is why Biden is like
polling better than Bernie
just like without without barely being
in the race yeah well so it's a couple
things it's name recognition it's to
some degree the idea that he's a safe
candidate it's to some degree the idea
from the Democratic establishment that
he's the best person to take on Trump so
I think the combination of different
things I haven't looked at numbers that
are slice and dice the way that you're
saying but I wouldn't be surprised I
mean Biden is to the right of Bernie so
it makes sense that since older people
are more conservative than younger
people I'm not saying they get more
conservative as they age which is a
common common but debunked myth but
older people are more conservative than
younger people right now that would
suggest that it's not unlikely that
Biden's support is coming
disproportionately from older voters
although I haven't looked at that data
but um from the different categories oh
yeah exactly exactly okay okay okay um
okay I kind of follow up after that do
you guys like how do you think that this
polling data will change by the time the
election comes at 2020 and if so how
drastically it will change but we're
starting to get so like it's May first
right now based on like the way things
have gone historically a few months ago
I was saying that the polling data it's
just too early to really give us a sense
of who are really the frontrunners who
have a shot in the Democratic primary by
May 15 and definitely by June 1st the
there will probably be three to four
candidates that are starting to kind of
separate and and you already are kind of
seeing this in Biden Sanders Warren
Budaj edge right now we're starting to
kind of become this upper tier I think
by June 1st you will have a much better
assessment of who is is going to be in
it for the long haul and that it won't
change nearly as drastically by Election
Day yeah I'm kind of with you but I
don't think it's gonna be like the four
candidates as you say I think it's
really just gonna be Biden and not
Bernie
maybe Warren but that's about it that
maybe Warren's been surging in fact
tomorrow on the show I'm gonna talk
about how Bernie has actually been hurt
over the last 10 days by by Warren
Biden and Warren have picked
and then Bernie has gone down and
everybody else is basically the same
especially because Warren killed at that
Town Hall she did and I really learnt
she's extraordinarily yeah Tony I'm
gonna mark you down as a very very good
call or a great connection great
question all right thank you okay take
care yep bye okay a couple other super
chats to get to let's see Leon Jones
says do you agree that Democrats are not
using all the legal options available to
them like punishing ignored subpoenas
which they should be using and given how
dire the situation is why not use all
the options they have to fight back 100
percent agree that Democrats are not
using all the options that they have
part of the reason may be that they want
to be careful about spending political
capital thinking that it may be best
spent in other ways or at other times a
Keith says and several others what's his
handle oh I see KKK was posted by
picture my love and several others
what's his handled Jimmy from Philly is
the guy who says he's banned fever
gaming says are you Pro legalizing ranch
hashtag eat boogies popcorn I don't know
anything about legalizing ranch
unfortunately Phillip Fenrir says Jimmy
has a huge crush on you David thank you
Robert Xavier Betancourt jr. with a $2
super chat Timothy white says what are
your thoughts on thorium based reactors
and do you think nuclear power should be
included in future clean energy policies
don't know much about thorium but I am
okay with including nuclear as part of
the plan to get to totally clean
renewable energy that does not include
nuclear so I'm okay with using nuclear
as a bridge the caveat being it takes a
while to get new nuclear supply on board
and that's just sort of a question mark
in terms of the practicality of it Omni
causality says what is the likelihood
you'll be able to appear on the scuffed
podcast alongside destiny on May 4 I
really hope you're able to do it no idea
what you're talking about no clue what
that podcast is haven't received any
invitations and May 4th I mean let me
look at wouldn't it when is May 4th
Saturday I try not to really do stuff on
the weekends but
you know step one would be for somebody
to actually invite me to whatever this
is let's go to our caller from the eight
one eight area code who's calling today
from eight one eight two questions for
you alright first of all do you think
that the ideology of neoconservatism is
very destructive when it comes to United
States foreign policy and my second
question would be a do thing
neoliberalism is a destructive economic
force when it comes to income inequality
environmental destruction court the the
corporation finance in our elections and
making people in third world countries
much poor so they have to migrate to the
Western world what would you have to say
to those two I would say yes and yes I
would say yes to both reduce but explain
to me in depth in the sense
y-yo conservatism is disrupted well if
the assuming we have the same definition
of well maybe let's actually back up
what specifically or do you mean when
you say neoconservative foreign policy
neoconservative foreign policies applied
to life during the george bush overlap
so Catering's uh during certain areas
the clinton administration with Somalia
Kosovo those things yes yes it's
basically two maybe even three primary
ways number one I am against using the
military to carry out political agendas
beyond sort of immediate defense or
defense of an allied country so to speak
just for like creating some kind of
working definition and neoconservatism
is a worldview that historically has
been used to justify use of the military
that did not meet that criteria and I
think that that's a net negative for
humans on earth which is basically that
you know it's the one place that humans
that humans exist so I think in that way
it's a negative force number two I think
that neoconservative foreign policy in
the same in much the same way that the
sort of nationalist sentiment that we've
seen rise under Donald Trump damages
important geopolitical relationships and
you know we can pretend that we can just
like fix things by ourselves and deal
with problems by ourselves but we really
can't I mean a lot of the problems that
humans are facing right now on the
planet are Planetary issues not issues
that respect sort of imaginary lines on
maps which which is effectively what
nation-states are and it does huge
damage both reputational ii given where
a lot of the world is politically and in
terms of negotiating relationships so
yeah i mean it's like we could go on but
i think it's hugely damaging but could
you make the claim that every
administration of that foreign policy
blunders yes even Trump Obama Bush and
Clinton absolutely and here's my second
question to you mr. Pakman drug you're a
very smart man okay you asked the second
question you said what about there you
have a second question yes here's my
second question okay what are the what
is more different aspects of neoliberal
economics that are destructive like we
did like I've got a full video on that
I've got I've got twenty people holding
and I recently did a full video on
neoliberalism it's on the web on the
youtube channel so check that out so
that I can continue getting to other
people okay okay videos on YouTube
alright I'm not gonna I'm not gonna read
you that I just did that like ten days
ago okay let's go to ma'am very
demanding people today let's go to our
caller from the 307 area code who's
calling today from 307 hey that's uh
Solomon from Wyoming hey man what's
going on hey yeah I love the show just
want to say that really quick thank you
so I'm from Wyoming and I don't really
here
lot of like rural issues being talked
about a lot on your show but now Oh a
lot of people I think in the future are
going to be moving to large cities like
they already have they've already kind
of flocked to urban areas and it's only
going to get worse over time where we
have less ranching and farming and more
you know just all the relationships of
workers change you know obviously right
so do you think it's generally a good
thing that people who move in the city
or do you think we should be making an
effort to get people back into roots
rural area to the country well I guess
the first question would be what the
goal of doing that would be so I mean
let's let's think about that is the idea
that you feel in some way the rural
areas are kind of being left behind yeah
I guess so in a way like there's there's
like a lot of beauty and like natural
resources out here I think maybe that a
lot of people in cities feel that they
wish they had that and they wish they
had this like sense of you know it's
connection to nature and stuffin and all
these people in the rural communities
are saying yeah like I would never give
that up or like a like a crummy City
that's all crowded and stuff I'm not
sure that's there we agree with that
before you know it's like I like getting
out of cities and spending time more in
more rural areas in nature and I've done
it in lots of different parts of the
country but if I really think about what
is it that keeps me from moving to those
places
I think it's ease of travel right like a
lot of those places are quite isolated
in terms of being able to travel with
nonstop flights for example to places
that I go frequently oftentimes the the
cultural scene is sort of depressed and
there of course there there are
exceptions to all of this stuff there's
places you know Hudson Valley New York
Western Massachusetts the five college
area where the show started there's all
sorts of places that are relatively
rural and have a lot of these things but
you know Wyoming is a level of rural
that for me in terms of like what my
lifestyle is would be tough and I don't
know that there would be like one or two
simple things that could be done
to get me to consider moving to such a
place I feel like there's a big cultural
divide that determines whether we're
more attracted to living in an urban
area or a rural area and I don't know
that there's like tweaks that can be
made to rural areas to make them much
more appealing to people who aren't into
that lifestyle yeah that's part of the
concern that hello it's weird
totally lost him okay that was that was
interesting let's look at a couple of
the super chats here what's going ok
horror fan for life says I believe Jimmy
is legitimately mentally ill I'm not
qualified to make that assessment
kwok-hing 15 says what do you think of
the idea of worker coops I think that
they're a great idea and I'm totally in
favor of any company or group of people
that want to organize that way to do it
I think it's great
real life Jolie says sorry David I was
the caller from two one seven that was
that crazy computer voice but when you
didn't answer me audibly
well audibly I was talking the whole
time I thought that you couldn't hear me
I got frustrated and hung up sorry okay
I have a different recollection of the
phone call
Matthew Griffin says you should pay
someone to manage your social media have
it be someone that you trust that can
navigate the chaos of social media I'm
guessing you mean my personal social
media rather than the shows yeah that's
an idea
Drake Jenson sends a $2.00 super chat
and then a $10 super jet saying since
May 5th is Karl Marx's birthday can we
get a video that specifically underlines
Marxism maybe have Richard Wolff on
again also found out the Buddha judges
father was a Marxist what are your
thoughts I didn't know that let me think
about that I'll think I'll think about
doing something like that Michael
wheeler sends a dollar and Zach Bushman
says what are your concerns with using
at nuclear energy long-term waste
disposal safety current renewable tech
struggles to meet baseload demand yeah
so ok I mean listen I know that if I say
that the issue is waste disposal there
will be people who are all about that
issue who will email me links to
articles saying that we figured out the
nuclear waste disposal if I say the
safety I will get people who rightly
email me and say the nuclear safety
issues of the past have been resolved
next generation nuclear deals with those
issues so for me it's not about pointing
out particulars that become sort of goal
posts for arguing around it's that I
believe that the right path forward is
one that you don't have to deal with
waste you don't have to deal with safety
in the same way oh yeah I know wind will
kill some birds and I'm familiar with
those talking points I believe that
eventually renewable technology will be
able to meet the demand without
outrageous restrictions on our habits
although we may have to sort of think a
little bit more seriously and
thoughtfully about our energy usage and
and demands that our lifestyles make but
we actually we I'm planning an upcoming
video on nuclear and we're gonna address
a lot of these issues there awry Suslov
says Erik or Don jr. for what I don't
know I don't even know how to answer
that
I think Erik is the Dumber one and Don
jr. may be the less ethical guy I don't
know okay let's take another call from
the five five one area code who's
calling today from five five one yes I
can I'm calling from New York City all
right about the US Navy drafting new
guidelines for the UFOs drafting
guidelines for what your connections not
the best for reporting a UFO for
reporting UFOs no I didn't see that okay
so they basically came out saying that
they're they acknowledge that there have
been intrusions on their airspace from
unidentified aircraft okay
I just wander your thought have no idea
now when you say unidentified aircraft
are you yo are you talking about aliens
or you're saying just foreign countries
Haitian yeah you don't know they don't
know where you don't they're you didn't
either or well maybe they know they said
they do you believe in aliens in outer
space yes I do but I'm talking about do
you think they've been here on our
planet
yeah but I'm asking in regards it's out
there because it's pretty big deal do
you think they've abducted anybody yeah
any reason to think they have you're
agnostic on that issue yeah got it
all right I will look into the
guidelines thank you very very much for
the phone call appreciate it
let me say thanks to a couple of other
new members Sam Appleton is a new patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
and owen mora wits is our newest david
pakman show member signing up on our
website okay I've got to go and I've got
to get home I've got to make dinner I'm
making egg biryani tonight it's going to
be an amazing thing so thanks to
everybody who called in joined me took a
lot of phone calls today I will do
another live stream again when the
demand calls for it I will leave it at
that